- Hey, my name is Ben Schwartz.
I'm here at BuzzFeed to talk
about my new film, Blue Iguana
with Sam Rockwell, coming
everywhere August 24th
and it, my friends,
is time to S some T
which means spill some tea.
Shall we?
(upbeat music)
Watch as I do it.
Hold.
Whenever you pour tea, gently cradle,
I call this the armpit
and as high as you can go
and as slow as you can go.
Join me.
I feel like when we look back at the show,
the writing staff of
that show is so strong.
If you look at it it's
like the best writers
and so when we got scripts it was always
the funniest thing I'd ever read
so we would always do it as is,
and I'll play a little
bit and then many times
we'll do something called
a fun run at the end
where you can kind of go nuts.
We got what we needed, go nuts.
Sometimes they keep some of
that, sometimes they don't
but the words were always great.
That show, the writers on that show,
it's a very special, special thing.
It was a really special show.
Jean-Ralphio and I have
many traits in common.
We have the same hair.
Anytime I played Jean-Ralphio
I would grow out my hair
as long as I could so when it came time,
I looked as stupid as I could.
Me and the hair and make up people
had like the best time making me look
like a crazy cartoon character
every time we did it.
(lighthearted music)
I would probably want
to switch with Pratt,
Pratt or Perd Hapley.
And I could never do Nick
Offerman's character,
he's just too perfect, like
I wouldn't be able to do it.
Yeah, I think I'd probably
say Pratt or Perd Hapley.
Perd Hapley is one of
my favorite characters
on all of television. (laughing)
I think he's so funny,
I think he's so funny.
I'm trying to think, most
of scenes were with Aziz
and he's incredibly funny.
Jenny really made me laugh.
Jenny's so funny, Jenny
really made me laugh.
Pratt, Pratt makes me laugh.
I don't know about cracking up on the spot
but anytime anybody improvised I would go,
it would make me so happy but oftentimes
when I'm in a scene, I'm the crazy person
and the the other
person's the straight man
because my character was
so insane. (laughing)
Everybody there, I'm talking
about like Retta, Jim,
everybody there, Amy is
obviously an icon, a legend.
They're all incredibly
funny, I don't remember,
I'm sure all of them made
me laugh at some time
because they're just amazing,
they're truly amazing.
I love those guys so much.
Can I say something about tea?
I do love tea and one of
the reasons why I love it
is that it's delicious, it's classy.
I mean, it's really hard to
know how much I enjoy it
until I really pour myself a
good cuppa, a good cuppa tea.
(playful music)
Yeah, one of my favorite
Jean-Ralphio lines is,
we're exiting a car,
we're exiting in a van,
it was after that episode where Nick
is dancing like this with a tiny hat
where everybody's drinking Snake Juice
and it's a very small line,
we're leaving and I'm in the back
and as the car pulls
away everybody's laughing
and as they pull away I go,
"I'm so alone." (laughing)
That's it, it's such a small line
and I can't believe it
made the cut. (laughing)
(people laughing)
I'm so alone.
I mean Don Cheadle to me, listen,
to be that good, he's such a good actor.
Cheadle's incredible, you what it is?
Kristen Bell like treated us like,
she was so incredible
and then took care of us
and then while she was
going that she had two kids
so like she was able to do everything
and manage everything and
then take care of us as well
which is incredible.
And Cheadle, man, you
just, it's like everyday
is like class, you could just sit back
and watch one of the
greatest actors of all time
do what he does and
also you gain confidence
because when you're in scenes with him,
you create with him and you
create something together
and so it's very exciting to
be around both of those people
for those reasons.
Can you guys be honest,
do I drink tea weird?
Because I'll so this in
a restaurant and be like.
I just like to get it on
the very ends of my lips.
(sipping tea)
(upbeat music)
I don't know, what do people
say about me? (laughing)
I don't know, what's happening?
Um, sometimes people will think
that I'm very much like Jean-Ralphio
because I played him or
that I'm a little bit
of a douche bag because of Jean-Ralphio
but I'm very much not like that.
I actually don't really get to go to clubs
or anything like that usually.
Oh yeah, this is some
mess, this is a mess.
What a mistake, and I stained my clothes
and I got more press today.
I can Venmo you for the rug, I think.
If I wanted to switch
characters with anybody
for a day, what would it be?
It is easy, it would probably
be either Sonic the Hedgehog
or Dewey Duck.
First of all, if I'm Sonic,
I can run as fast as anybody
and I'm also a hedgehog
and I guess I love rings
so I'm very into that.
It probably would be Sonic,
how could would that be?
I can turn into a ball.
What are you crazy?
I would love that!
The process of me getting
Sonic was a long one,
a really long one, it started a year ago.
Where was I?
I think the director, Jeff, called me
and he said that, "The role is yours."
I did like a Tiger Woods one of these,
I went, "Yeah!"
like fist pumped and then looked around
because I was out in the open.
That one was a, I put in a
lot of work to get that one,
I really wanted it so I
was very, very excited.
Hey my name is Ben Schwartz and I am still
at BuzzFeed.
(lighthearted music)
This has been so much fun.
Listen, we spilled some tea literally.
Check me out with Sam Rockwell
in a movie called Blue
Iguana, August 24th.
It is gonna be on SVOD which I think means
everywhere that you can
download things on demand?
I'm assuming?
And then it's gonna be in
theaters as well, same time
and Sam Rockwell just won an Oscar
so I mean like, there's way
more pressure for him than me.
Enjoy the movie. (laughing)
This is the most serious
interview I've done,
no joke, you can ask them.
Every other interview
has been me going crazy
and it's at BuzzFeed
which seems like the place
that you would go the most crazy.
(dry erase marker squeaking on whiteboard)